At the end of our last lesson, I showed you an example of how to start with the
equation for a parabola in standard form and then work through modifying it, so
that it's in the form that we can just read off the coordinates of the vertex.
Now you're going to get a chance to find this. But don't worry. I'll help you
through it. Let's say we're dealing with the equation, y eqiuals x squared minus
8x plus 15. Remember our goal here is to get this in the form y minus k equals
the quantity x minus h squared. So the first thing that I notice about this form
over here that we're aiming for is that we have y minus a constant. So one
logical first step would be to get the constant that's on the right side, to be
over on the left side instead. So the first thing I'd like you to do then is to
make that change, getting the constant term to be on the left hand side instead.
And rewrite the equation in this box.